now Sudan's government signed a peace
deal with the ESPE lmn rebel group the
forms part of a larger peace plan for
blue nile and south kordofan regions the
Sudanese people's liberation movements
been fighting the government since 2011
just before South Sudan gained
independence from Sudan talks between
the rebels and the transitional
government began last November almost
400,000 people have been displaced by
the conflict and as hipa Morgan reports
a new government says is determined to
reach deals with other rebel groups in
the country the peace deal that has been
signed today in the South Sudanese
capital Juba mediated by a South Sudan
is between the Sudanese government and
the armed groups who dance people
liberation movement north led by America
gar let's not forget that the s balaam
North has two factions one that is led
by Malecha a guard who has forces in
blue nile area in the southern part of
sudan as well as a faction led by abdul
aziz and Helou who controls areas in
South Kordofan and Blue Nile and the
deal that has been signed today between
Malika gaara's group and the government
includes security arrangements which
means where will Medicare guards forces
go now that a deal has been signed
between him and the government and
includes their integration the deal also
includes humanitarian access to those
who have been displaced and affected by
the word that started in 2011 just
before South Sudan gained its
independence but the government is also
engaged in other peace talks and that is
yet to produce results the government is
right now engaged in talks between it
and the and rebel groups from Darfur and
it says that it wants to achieve
comprehensive peace in various armed
zones in Sudan before February and right
now they as they're holding talks there
are other factions that are holding out
and not ready to hold to negotiate with
student Sudan's governments so while
this is significant a lot remains to be
done for the Sudanese government to
achieve that aim of a comprehensive
peace that they have been talking about